survive the next 50 hours in this remote
cabin
have you ever considered just quitting
your career in society and just
I have at least just for a few days I
don't know my phone oh no
it's for emergency calls only because I
don't have access to Internet Power
Plumbing and I'm here to get some
distance and figure out what I really
want in life this is where I live for
the next few days I do trips like these
every once in a while to reevaluate what
I want out of life do I really want to
go after these massive career goals and
build a big business or I just want a
little
Simple Life
just focus on being happy how do you
decide what life is right for you so I
decided to try the extreme version of
this and collect my thoughts I want to
live the full simple life experience
which means make a fire find something
to eat maybe even hunt an animal and
most importantly I want to have tamed an
animal
I've been warned there's coyotes deer
Longhorns and supposedly a newborn baby
donkey
I must find the baby donkey tame it ride
it become best friends with it the sun's
going down I should start making a fire
it's stuck my swing was too powerful
Andrew can you just make it look like I
did in one shot
[Music]
no
recently I've been asking myself you can
go after your biggest dreams and the
highest achievements but are you willing
to pay the price because a lot of the
people that have reached the Pinnacle of
success they're kind of miserable
Andrew just cut to the next scene
you know so far I've achieved a lot of
things
that initially I thought were impossible
you know 20 years old building my first
business scaling it up to seven figures
moving to Australia to be reunited with
my first girlfriend at the time and even
get into the US that was a dream of mine
where I thought once I achieved that
I'll be happy I mean you know it too
like any goal you've set that you
thought once I achieved this then I'm
gonna be happy it doesn't really do that
[Music]
I mean in past three is you've seen me
struggle with dialing back the ambition
and just enjoying life I feel like
especially in the western world that's
what most people do they work their way
up to middle management chase their
careers logically we all know that
doesn't make us happy but it seems to be
this battle between these two forces the
pursuit of happiness and the pursuit of
significance of success
either way it's time to get the fire
going because it's getting freezing now
keeping it simple I have a little
survival kit let me show you how it's
done
yes
ah Andrew can you just edit this real
quick
whoa
should you really achieve your highest
goals if that means you have a severe
price to pay you have overachievers like
Robin Williams achieved everything he
ever wanted and the Oscar goes to Robin
Williams thank you so much actor Robin
Williams is dead at the age of 63 from
an apparent suicide what if you spend
entire life going after your goals and
then by the end you realize man I wish I
would have just raised a family lived on
a little farm how can you achieve your
wildest dreams while also being happy
I'm also going to put out some deer feed
now because supposedly in the evening
that's when the beer come to the cabin
oh
Mouse may I seduce you with a pecan it's
my chance to tame my first animal I'm
gonna put the pecan right here
and see if it's still there tomorrow I
do have my other ring as always so
curious how the Sleep scores are once
I'm back so tomorrow we're gonna go
explore find the animals baby donkey
night
good morning it was very cold I woke up
so many times from I think it was
coyotes
do they bark let's see if the deer feed
is gone which means the animals are
around and I can finally tame one the
little pecan is gone which means Mickey
took it last night yes I need the mouse
Mickey I guess that's our first animal
friend
doesn't look like they were here
where are they
where's the baby donkey
look who we have here now they're the
Longhorns
all right I let them win the staring
contest I'll come back later I'm gonna
find the the baby donkey
I once heard a famous author say every
child you have is a bestseller you
didn't write writing a bestseller takes
so much time and work and effort same as
having a child so I'm here thinking do I
want kids I mean I think I do but you
gotta know that I just think you have to
reflect what do I really want not what
do I want to want but what do I actually
want because if you never really Define
that other people will do that for you
and I've been there you know you've seen
it in previous videos like the brain
training video where I had to really get
honest with myself it's very freeing
when you realize you've been chasing
something that you actually don't want
so you just let it go
see something in the distance that looks
exactly like a baby donkey but it can't
be wait a second right there do you see
that maybe it just looks like it
I don't know let's find out
yes something's moving
donkey's coming towards me already oh
there's the baby
I found it now I just need to tame it so
I'm gonna get the Keras out and just
have them follow me to the cabin ah you
recognize this I have it right here
yes
they're eating the carrots they're
falling for my trickery trust me I mean
no harm
yeah come here
yes all right everyone who wants more
carrots just follow me
[Music]
anyone hello
they are following me
the baby is definitely shy curious to
see if I'm able to become friends with
it I want to touch it just once looks
really fluffy come on
the baby's name is cupcake
I made it back
donkeys are here
I'm happy
funny enough I also brought an
autobiography with me and it's not what
you might expect
there's just so many ways life can be
lived you can be a fisherman in Vietnam
or someone like Dan Bilzerian who just
lives a lavish rock star lifestyle and I
don't think there's a black and white
right or wrong way I think the only way
to know is to just try stuff when I was
younger I thought I wanted a lifestyle
business where I can travel the world
and live in multiple countries and I did
that and it was very lonely I wanted to
build something together with people and
I only knew that because I tried the one
thing and it didn't work for me so this
is the male donkey star he's the most
confident unfortunately take it easy
buddy okay take it easy you're a good
boy baby one do you want okay here I'll
give you one so that you stay occupied
and you stay out of my way
all right what happens when I run out of
carrots
cupcake oh this guy again problem is
baby donkey's too shy
this guy is not shy enough
I'm trying to distract the big boy the
pet cupcake dear feed should be fine for
donkeys yeah
I want to come over here as you have at
it yes it's working
do you want a little carrot
a plan did not work as expected
I don't think it's going to happen
cupcake maybe tomorrow you'll trust me
more
well I'm gonna practice bow and arrow
until I hit this bottle let me tell you
about the book essentialism that I
recently went through again I didn't
read the whole thing again just uh the
essentials by using the sponsor of this
video short form they make these
beautiful guides and summaries of
non-fiction books from all kinds of
genres and the author talks about the
disciplined pursuit of less the things
that matter most to you
I'm joking he also says it all starts by
defining what you actually want what is
your purpose if you don't know that you
don't know what to say no to what to do
more of
for me short form is a great way to
remember the biggest lesson of my
favorite books and it also helps me
decide what book I'm willing to invest
time into they drop new book guides and
articles every week and subscribers get
to vote what book to cover next
you ready
if you want to get five days of full
access and a 20 discount on the annual
subscription then just use my magic link
shortfarm.com Leon or click the link in
the description
yeah
another day in the middle of nowhere
what a simple beautiful day
you can really feel how good this is for
me nothing to do other than make food
feed the donkeys make a fire Andrew no
need to edit this one I can handle this
I want to have more trips like this just
out in nature for a few days I deal with
friends because it's kind of lonely I'd
like to use this time to connect with
someone more deeply but even just by
yourself for a day is amazing oh I'm
gonna sleep well tonight
now Mickey's taken care of as well what
a long and fun day
I've got about 10 hours left here I'm
gonna pet cupcake good morning cupcake
okay don't walk away please
[Music]
the problem is I only have one carrot
left and this boy is hungry just make a
quick move over here
cupcake please nope nope I'm doing this
close this may be my chance
oh
I'm so close
I dropped my hat
I think one thing you can't argue with
is that a simpler life is definitely
better for your mental health but I know
I want to have a wild adventurous life I
want to go after really exciting goals
and I believe there is a way to have the
best of both worlds that was it
no more carrots if cupcake doesn't want
me around then that's fine I'll just
choose to be around those who
who want to be around me as well
this whole time
I think in the end as long as you're
happy and fulfilled you've won the game
of life doesn't matter how much you
achieve no that's my hat please and
that's how I want to live my life do
with that information whatever you want
thanks for your time I'll see you in the
next one
walking around with a snack
when all of a sudden
whoa